m
dans le cadre du projet carnet de voyage
mis en place par le conseil
départemental 265 enfants se sont rendus
à l'espace régler à l'occasion de la
restitution de leur travail
une opération menée par la bibliothèque
départementale qui consiste à faire
découvrir aux enfants d'autres cultures
cette année un véritable voyage
littéraire a été fait sur le continent
africain à travers divers ateliers
depuis 2013 l'idée c'est de faire
voyager les enfants à travers la
littérature et l'art en 2013 on est allé
dans les îles du sud ouest de l'océan
indien
en 2014 nous sommes allés en inde et
cette année nous sommes allés en afrique
à la découverte du continent africain
donc onze classes de saint denis ont
participé à cette opération ça va de la
petite section à une classe de collège
et l'idée c'est de découvrir un pays ou
un continent à travers la littérature la
bibliothèque départementale a accueilli
sur cinq séances les classes qui ont
appris la richesse du continent africain
les élèves ont réalisé une boîte
explosive représentant une maison
africaine tout au long de leur année
scolaire
donc là ils ont constitué l'intérieur
avec la carte de l'afrique leulliot
qu'ils ont eux-mêmes colorier collet et
après il y avait aussi une biographie de
l'angle en terre d'afrique donc dans le
lit dans le la boîte explosif et de
prostituées par des séances trois
séances donc c'était la constitution du
ben baba avec
un peu dénudée le magot bab et ont
constitué le petit africain
donc ensuite
chacun a voulu raconter leur histoire
d'après le dessin les couleurs qu'ils
ont présentés au niveau de l'afrique
la restitution de leur carnet de voyage
représente un moment fort pour les
enfants après le voyage bien le partage
et c'est avec fierté que les élèves ont
présenté leurs réalisations
j'ai appris comment décorer une maison
et ben comment faire un
et comme en face à la crinière
et pendant que
peinture baissé de payer
et ben voilà
et on a pour tout chose désolée
l'histoire le début de mon histoire
commence ici c'est un jeune oiseau
célibataire et il cherche l'amour de sa
vie
un jour il avait vu sur son beau sur son
bel arbre ils rêvent de trouver ça
fameux bien aimée et le lendemain il
trouve ensuite plus ensuite il le zoo
fait la rencontre
ils sont sortis ensemble et l'après midi
il a une grosse tempête ils ont trouvé
un abri est il résolu beaucoup d'enfants
pour les parents ce projet permet de
sensibiliser les enfants à la
littérature et au patrimoine mais
également de faciliter leur
appropriation des collections de la
bibliothèque à travers des activités
ludiques
ça leur permet de découvrir des
moqueries qui a pris en main forcément
et ça fait travailler l'imaginaire ça
fait travailler l'histoire
notions d'histoire ça fait travailler
leur créativité enfin voilà non vraiment
c'est très simple